RStudio Cloud
currently supports three project types,
RStudio projects,
projects from a Git repository,
and our newest feature, Jupyter Projects.
This means that as instructors,
we have a good deal of flexibility
over the coding environment
we create for our learners,
and that we can teach using
both R and Python
within the same cloud-based environment.
We can access each of these project
types by clicking on the arrow
in the right hand side of the new projects
button. When we select RStudio project,
we're taken to a new untitled project
within the RStudio IDE.
When we select Jupyter Project
we're taken to a new untitled project
that gives us all
of the same functionality
we expect from within a Jupyter Project,
including the ability to upload files,
as well as create
new Python notebooks
using specific versions of Python.
We can also clone a new RStudio
or Jupyter project from a git
repository. For RStudio projects
we simply provide the URL of
the corresponding git repository,
while for Jupyter we can accomplish this
by cloning our repository
from a new terminal within a Jupyter
project on RStudio Cloud.
RStudio support for Jupyter
projects is exciting,
although at the time of this recording,
the feature is still in beta.
We would love to hear your feedback,
and you can always reach out to us
on the community
forums at community.rstudio.com/c/rstudio-cloud